now when I make some of these videos and
I come up with some of these ideas I
kind of think what kind of videos i like
to make and I think of discussion videos
I like discussion videos because it gets
the the user into the video it gets them
interested they give feedback we all
have a general conversation about
whatever topic I bring the that I bring
up we're going to be talking about as
the title states the gun game mode or if
there could be one and if there is what
this work so the people that don't know
what a gun game mode is or unfamiliar
with it it was a gun it was a mode used
in Call of Duty way back when which
eventually moved on to other titles like
Battlefield called gun master or in
dirty bomb this game would consisted of
players going through various weapons in
the game to see who could get a kill
with each weapon the fastest for example
if this was in titanfall I could have I
would start with like let's say the R
201 I get a kill I switch on to the
hemlock I get a kill with the hemlock I
go to the p26 dead 2016 sort of the [ __ ]
the pistols called and then after that
lets say I go to the wingman and then I
go all the way up and up and up until
the last one weapon which is usually a
melee weapon and for titan falls case it
would be a type of like melee now the
way now the only way to stop players
from getting to the highest rank of the
weapon is by mailing them if you mail a
someone they go down a weapon if you get
a kill with a weapon you go up a weapon
stuff like that so that's for the people
if they don't really know how this would
work but I made this discussion to talk
about if titanfall could benefit from
this for example it could get more
players to use other weapons and have
newer players find their favored weapon
quicker sometimes whenever I play a new
game I kind of end up fiddling around
with weapons like for example in this
game I was fiddling around with credits
luckily there was a beta so I could find
out my favorite weapon and it took me
forever to find out what that weapon was
what was my favorite what clicked with
me with gun game all the weapons are
displayed there and all the newer
players can find out ahead of time what
their favorite gun would be the only
problem with
gun game mode is that it can mean that
other players are leaving game modes to
go to this one leaving some game modes
less populated or this could be left out
in the dust like maybe mixtape I mean
mixtape is still populated I play that
from time to time but it's still not as
populated as attrition in bounty hunt
you don't get too many games on there so
this could be just a waste of time and
just the game mode that no one ever
plays because of the low player count
and now this is where I leave it to you
guys the viewers and I want you all to
go into the comments and tell me what
your opinion would be tell me if a gun
game mode would be good tell me if it
wouldn't be good and then list your
reason why I'm very curious to hear
that's why I make these discussion
videos so that someone can comment
saying that they want the gun game mode
and then they can give their feedback
and then people could like argue it not
in a harsh way but kind of give your
kind of give your own opinion so we can
all formulate something I like to make
these discussions a lot when you guys
like the video comment in the comment
down below like if this would be a great
idea or not I kind of just thought of
the soft top of my head and then
subscribe if you're new I'm coming out
with a couple more videos in the coming
days related to discussions as well so
be on the lookout for that guys and uh
peace out